new rules guys need to get it through
their head that the only thing sadder
that you going on about football is you
going on about fantasy football
and by the way if you delight in
imagining having a bunch of young fit
athletes and what it'd be like if they
played for your team it's pretty clear
what your real fantasy is new rule cut
some slack to the Alabama Walmart that
was selling gun which is a personal
lubricant used by gay men selling it in
their actual gun department it's Alabama
you'll find their cheese nips in the
Asian food section
new rule someone has to tell Walmart who
just announced they're going to try to
appeal to middle-class shoppers that
there is no more middle class and even
if there was the single biggest
advantage to make it a get into the
middle class is never ever epic to set
foot in Walmart new rule playboy has to
fess up about the real reason they
decided to stop showing pubic hair in
the magazine it's 2015 nobody has any
new rules summit at Costco has to tell
me how I'm supposed to sample this
toilet paper
it's creepy enough when you serve me the
key lime pie in that little plastic cup
that makes it look like Shrek left to
sperm sample
and finally new rule Americans have to
make a list of all the reasons we've
heard over the years why young men with
guns use them in mass shootings things
like violent video games poor mental
healthcare bad parents Marilyn Manson
lack of prayer in school prozac bullying
and that time the president got blown
and didn't go to jail and then we have
to get real about what it really is they
can't get laid
yes they may have been on Prozac because
they were feeling blue but you know what
else was feeling blue they're balls now
as the details emerge about our latest
American massacre this month at an
Oregon College the least surprising
thing was at the shooter wrote a
manifesto and said he was going to die
girlfriendless
and a virgin on a dating site called
spiritual singles he was on he described
himself as a conservative Republican who
lives with his parents and swipe left
the shooter at the UC Santa Barbara
tragedy last year left us with these
words I've been forced to endure an
existence of unfulfilled desires all
because girls have never been attracted
to me I've never even kissed a girl
and I will punish you all for it which
is either a cry for help or the worst a
harmony profile I've ever heard Lee
Virginia Tech shooter was accused of
following and harassing female students
Timothy McVeigh famously never had a
date and almost certainly died a virgin
the Sandy Hook killer left a document on
his computer explaining quote why
females are inherently selfish
yes plainly because they won't give it
up to a real catch like that
this is a pattern no one is talking
about mass killers are almost always
male and almost always women repellent
and what must make it even worse for
them is America yeah because if you live
in America it just looks like everyone
is getting laid all the time every
corner of social media is full of
bragging studs and sexy selfies every
other line in every sitcom is sexual
innuendo every billboard pop-up movie
Carl's jr. ads are practically softcore
porn a model deepthroating a hamburger
right like models eat how can you not be
thinking of sex all the time when
advertising looks like this in America
Burger King ran this ad with a woman who
looks just like an inflatable doll
opening her mouth to accommodate a new
menu item called the super 7-inch ur
with the big letters it'll blow your
mind away I don't I don't know for a
fact that no man in history has ever
said sex sex sex that's all I ever do
where's my gun I'm mad at the world I
just know it's true unrealized
adolescent sexuality can be very
dangerous
just ask my hand
we need to wake up and smell the
testosterone the reason behind so many
of these tragedies has been right in our
face throbbing angrily and if you think
young men in America are throbbing
angrily what would you estimate the
sexual frustration level to be for a
young man who grows up only ever seeing
women who look like this or this how do
you even masturbate to that I know
masturbation requires imagination but
that's ridiculous
you